on va se prêter au jeu de la
vérification des faits sur le thème de
l'immigration avec nous d'ail Diallo
économiste principale à l'Institut du
Québec bonjour monsieur Diallo bonjour
madame Laurent d'abord 80% des
immigrants qui arrivent au Québec
s'installe à Montréal dit le ministre
sortant de l'immigration Jean Boulay
est-ce que c'est vrai ou c'est faux
c'est un chiffre qui n'est pas
exactement vrai selon les données à peu
près 85% des émigrants qui arrivent au
Québec s'installe dans la grande région
de Montréal au tout début donc on parle
la grande région de Montréal si on
regarde juste au niveau de la Ville de
Montréal de l'île de Montréal c'est à
peu près 65%. donc c'est un peu plus
c'est un peu plus petit juste pour
Montréal et dans quelle mesure
travailles-tu selon les données dont
vous disposez c'est très intéressant
madame Morin on a une étude qui est
sortie en juin qui a essayé de voir
l'évolution de l'immigration au cours de
la dernière décennie et en matière
d'intégration au marché du travail on se
rend compte que l'intégration des
immigrants ces dernières années au
Québec quand on regarde par exemple
l'indicateur comme le taux d'emploi on
se rend compte que entre avril 2012 et
avril 2022 le taux d'emploi des
immigrants est passé de à peu près 70 à
82 % on se rend compte que si en matière
de chômage le taux de chômage des
immigrants à fortement diminué durant la
dernière décennie on a pu passer de 12,7
% à 5,3 % de chômage et aussi on se rend
compte qu'avec les natifs c'est tout là
se resserre donc au Québec la situation
du marché du travail qui est très serré
en ce moment la situation de notre
démographie fait en sorte que la
situation et les propices à une
meilleure intégration des émigrants sur
le marché du travail et peut-être un
petit point que l'on peut rajouter à ça
c'est que les immigrants permanents que
l'on reçoit au Québec au niveau de
l'immigration économique sont de plus en
plus des immigrants qui étaient déjà au
Québec avant avec un permis temporaire
donc des étudiants qui ont c'est ça donc
des étudiants qui ont obtenu leur
diplôme ici ou qui travaillaient déjà
ici donc des gens qui sont déjà intégrés
quoi c'est ce qui explique aussi qu'on a
ces taux là qui s'améliore et qu'on a
une meilleure intégration économique et
dans le marché du travail de
l'immigration permanente donc c'est un
élément important d'avoir des gens déjà
ici de les encourager ou de leur
permettre de rester de façon permanente
ça a un gros effet sur l'intégration
économique c'est ce que vous voyez dans
vos données c'est ce que l'on voit
effectivement dans les données et
effectivement au niveau des données
économiques les gens qui sont ici ont
une meilleure capacité d'intégration je
vous donne un autre point au niveau des
salaires on s'est rendu compte que
durant la dernière décennie quand un
immigrants permanent arrivé au Québec ou
du moins obtenait sa permanence la
première année quand il déclarait un
salaire environ il y avait une
différence de 40% elles sont salaire
déclaré et la moyenne la médiane
québécoise pardon en 2019 c'est un petit
plus que 1,3% et cela s'explique comme
je vous ai dit une grosse différence
donc c'est une amélioration autant pour
les immigrants que pour la richesse de
Québec en général donc oui selon les
données économiques d'avoir des
immigrants permanents qui ont déjà été
des immigrants temporaires par le passé
augmente cette améliore cette
intégration là sur le marché du travail
cette intégration économique là
qu'est-ce qu'on sait sur la langue
d'intégration des nouveaux résidents
permanents ça c'est un très bon point
quand vous regardez les données du wi-fi
donc vous savez quand vous êtes nouveau
les en permanent au Québec et que vous
avez donc certificat de sélection du
Québec le mi-fi collecte des données sur
la capacité à parler le français donc en
regardant l'aspect connaissance du
français en 2021 on a les données pour
les six premiers mois en 2021 72% des
immigrants déclarés pouvoir déclarer
connaître le français en 2019 en 2020
pardon c'était 60% et donc c'est ces
données là elles s'améliorent et en 2021
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles ces
données s'améliorent c'est aussi comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure avec la
covid 19 et la fermeture des frontières
on a reçu au Québec beaucoup plus
d'immigrants permanent qui était avant
les émirates temporaires donc il était
déjà sur le territoire du Québec et donc
il parlait déjà français et ou du moins
qui était confronté aux faits français
donc ça améliore aussi ce indicateur là
que l'on a pu voir dans les données le
Premier ministre le goût craint
d'accueillir plus de 50 000 immigrants
par année parce qu'il s'est suicidaire
pour la nation québécoise le fait
français la fameuse capacité
d'intégration la capacité d'accueil
est-ce que c'est possible de la définir
en ce moment avec les indicateurs qu'on
a en ce moment est-ce qu'on peut la
calculer c'est quelque chose qui est
très difficilement calculable il
n'existe pas d'indicateurs là-dessus
venant des autorités ou du moins pour la
plupart des études qui sont effectuées
sur ces thématiques là mais ce que l'on
peut voir par exemple si des indicateurs
économiques comme nous on l'a démontré
cette intégration là qui s'améliore au
niveau économique mais vous savez madame
Morin l'un des anges au Québec aussi
au-delà des seuils c'est la
régionalisation de l'immigration parce
qu'on en parlait un peu tout à l'heure
85% des immigrants s'installe en général
dans la grande région de Montréal quand
on parle de seuil on peut le voir au
niveau des politiques publiques est-ce
que on pourrait faire avec la situation
de l'immigration qui s'améliore
l'économiquement il est besoin de
marcher du travail québécois besoin qui
sont aussi importants sinon plus
importants à la région on a des taux de
post vacances qui sont importants on a
une population active qui baisse en
région et qui augmente par exemple à
Montréal ce serait de d'augmenter ses
seuils là en priorisant la
régionalisation de l'immigration et
surtout est-ce que ça se fait
concrètement en fait
d'amener les gens à immigrer dans les
régions est-ce qu'on le voit est-ce
qu'on ça commence à porter fruits les
plans qui sont mis en place dans les
données on commence à voir un tout petit
peu plus les régions qui accueillent un
nombre plus important des migrants on le
voit sur les deux dernières années mais
ce n'est pas encore significatif et donc
vous savez madame Morin comme je le
disais tout à l'heure en matière le
seuil l'idée se serait vraiment
d'augmenter ces seuila mais en
priorisant l'immigration en région donc
c'est d'avoir les 50000 par exemple que
le gouvernement du Québec a aujourd'hui
en matière de seuil mais au-delà de ce
50 000 là permettre dis personnes de
pouvoir s'installer à la région à
travers des programmes qui feraient en
sorte que ces gens-là sont privilégiés
s'ils veulent s'installer à les gens et
surtout aussi prioriser cette émigration
temporaire qui est déjà présente qui
s'intègre mieux économiquement à rester
en région s'il veut l'immigré de manière
permanente merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci
Madame au revoir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI